this is a driverless vehicle in the wild
amongst the public with no backup driver
it's the Transport Research Laboratories
Meridian shuttle it doesn't look like a
sports car but that's not the point
doesn't have to now new Tesla vehicles
do have autopilot which is very shiny
but isn't that different from the Lane
Assist systems we've had for a few years
they can't drive on their own Google's
autonomous cars sound great but they
don't work in snow or heavy rain yet and
they require a driver that's alert and
ready to take over just in case this
vehicle you tap a button on a
touchscreen and it genuinely drives
itself without a backup driver behind
the wheel doesn't even have a wheel now
this is only a trial but for a vehicle
that is among real pedestrians it's got
a surprising amount of speed to it so
let's go back 150 years the locomotive
act 1865 limited all horseless carriages
to four miles an hour
- in cities and it required them to have
a man walk in front with a big red flag
wide high-vis jacket just in case it
sounds ridiculous now but remember there
were 50 years away from the Model T Ford
those were steam powered vehicles all
coal and soot they were new they were
scary and there was a risk that they
would fail catastrophically that's kind
of where we are with driverless vehicles
I mean they're slow they're cranky
admitted there's a lot less risk of
catastrophic failing without a steam
boiler but they're still curiosities
over the century that followed the
locomotive act we learn the risks of
cars we learn to accept a lot of them
worldwide more than a million people a
year die on the roads a million we
accept that risk because we're used to
it and because the alternative means our
world doesn't work anymore in 50 years a
descendant of this shuttle might be
whisking people around at much higher
speeds and in safety and they will look
back at this early step and think really
they didn't even allow them on public
roads they had to have large recent
markings on the front just in case they
scared people how quaint and then we'll
tell our cars to take us home and we
won't think any more about it
you